the Pentagon is heavily involved in the
coronavirus response and the search for
a vaccine in fact here to talk about all
of that is defense secretary Mark Esper
he joins us from the Pentagon mr.
secretary thanks for being here thanks
Brett thank you for having me I
understand you just got off the phone
with the governor of New York Andrew
Cuomo can you tell us about that
conversation the governor had been
wanting to deploy Army Corps of
Engineers will you sure let me let me
say one thing first of all I wanted to
assure all of your viewers that the
United States military remains ready and
capable of defending the American people
protect the nation and safeguarding our
interests abroad and and in that context
our second focus has been on supporting
the president and the whole of
government approach to the coronavirus
now in that context I've had a call with
a number of governors this today this
morning later today I had a call with
Governor Cuomo we had a very good
conversation he is very interested in
getting the Corps of Engineers engaged
because what he sees is a deficit if you
will in hospital beds in New York State
as he looks ahead to what may be coming
I gave him my full commitment that we
would get the Corps of Engineers up
there soonest to assess the problem and
see how we can help out so today you
announced you would be giving five
million respirator masks and 2,000
ventilators to HHS to slow the outbreak
you also said that that's just a drop in
the bucket what else could the US
military do potentially sure Brett we're
laying in in a number of ways so we're
offering up the ventilators protective
gear as some of which you mentioned we
are making available are filled
hospitals and our hospital ships as they
become available we of course can we
have the National Guard that has already
been activated in 18 states nearly 2,000
Guardsmen are available and also we're
doing considerable work in terms of our
vaccines and therapeutics I had a chance
today to go to Fort Detrick in Maryland
it is a world-class facility the US Army
there has been on the cutting edge of a
number of infectious diseases as you may
recall they helped with the solution to
both Ebola and Zika and they are working
pretty aggressively to come up with a
vaccine for the corona virus
well what are the estimates there tell
me about that Fort Dietrich visit
what are they saying is it is it along
the same lines of a year to 18 months or
are they they hoping to get something
quicker they're still looking at at that
12 to 18 month period although there are
outside companies that think they can
cut that time down a little bit in which
case again the US military would be
standing by ready to support and
accelerate any type of production
efforts but I think the 12 to 18 month
time line is what we're looking at now
in the meantime they're also working on
therapeutics you know ways to address
symptoms etc and that work is underway
as well and then the third part of this
and we're working very closely I should
say with with HHS is accelerating the
development of new testing mechanisms so
we can do testing for Americans in
volume and that seems to be very
promising too you know US military
members infected went from 18 to 36
today doubling how worried are you
you've got obviously Navy sailors on
ships you've got some you know on
submarines obviously there's a lot of
close quarters when you talk about
different elements of the US military
how worried does defense secretary argue
about the spread of this virus I am
concerned about our force and our
families that's my top priority in with
regard Crona virus followed by
maintaining our mission capabilities but
I will tell you we also have a very
young robust and healthy healthy Army
Navy Air Force and Marines and I think
they're sustaining this pretty well
we're also taking a lot of actions that
have been advised by CDC into account
and implementing them such as social
distancing changing our habits using
sanitary wipes to to wipe down equipment
and doorknobs and things like that we're
taking a number of precautions when you
when you escalate up to ships at sea for
example when a crew goes aboard they
have 14 days at least between stops
between port calls that they're not
transmitting the virus ashore so we're
taking any number of measures to make
sure that we protect the force and we
sustain our ability to react and respond
to any any challenges or any threats mr.
secretary I guess the question I get
most and we're going to deal with
viewers questions in the segment or two
about
you know how bad could this get and how
different is it from h1n1 and what is
the difference we listen to obviously
all the experts say about you know the
the can the contagious nature of it the
fact that that the elderly and also the
immune deficient really get hit hard but
you've been in these classified
briefings how bad could it get look I
think what you're hearing publicly from
the CDC is what I'm hearing privately as
well in terms of the range of estimates
I think the decisive action that
President Trump took here in the last 24
hours 48 hours to ask the American
people to stand down to stay in for the
next 15 days to avoid large groups will
go a long way towards breaking the cycle
if we can and flattening out that curve
and that's all the same things I'm
hearing privately from our experts
you know from DoD's perspective again I
need to maintain the force maintain our
national military mission capabilities
and we're taking all positive actions to
do such that we have plans in place
we've been implementing them now for
several weeks and we're also wanting to
lean for it and support again the whole
government approach to assist the
American people last thing I know where
we are now with the guidelines out of
the CDC but have you been asked to look
at options how the US military would
deal with some sort of national
quarantine or factor into that I don't
know but what we're looking at is not
necessarily a national quarantine but
how can we help affected areas where the
whether it's states or localities our
first line of defense right now it's a
National Guard I was a Guardsmen for
many years so I know their mission
they're doing a great job and like I
said I talked to a few governors today
about how we can improve the mission but
we also have other capabilities such as
our hospital ships our field hospitals
our deployable equipment in assets and
the reserves and the active component if
it gets to that to assist localities the
challenge we face though is so much of
our gear and our capabilities are
focused toward trauma and at the same
time those same hospitals they often
draw from the reserves which means the
civilian workforce so we're very
conscious as we deploy filled hospitals
that were not robbing Peter to pay Paul
when it comes to men
professionals so as we sort through the
problems as we respond to states and
cities and localities we want to make
sure we're conscious of what we're doing
and that we're not creating problems
elsewhere in the force defense secretary
Marquez for mr. secretary we appreciate
your time thanks Brett